there's there's four types of change
that happen in life and they start with
this really simple idea of imagine a
vertical line and at the top of it is a
voluntary change and at the bottom is an
involuntary and involuntary changes
where you choose to change I've
mentioned before this graphic designer
who decided to go back and take classes
he made a voluntary change and an
industrial designer I know didn't want
to change didn't want to learn AutoCAD
and an involuntary change happened to
him he lost his job there's all these
moments in life where we get to choose
to change or change happens to us but
not every voluntary change is good and
not every involuntary change is bad
we've all voluntarily gone to the wrong
job for longer than we should we've all
voluntarily dated idiots longer than we
should
we've all had involuntary things happen
to us that were good too
I think about Dave Barnes my musician
friend in Nashville where I live and he
had a song go number one Blake Shelton
the country music star recorded a song
of his called God gave me you and it
changed Dave's life forever as a
songwriter if you ask him how did Blake
Shelton find out about that song he'll
tell you he rented a car it hurts at the
airport and the previous person who had
rented it had programmed a station that
Blake never listens to and he got in the
car and he turned it on in my song that
I was singing came on and Blake Shelton
said you know what I'm married to
Miranda Lambert or in this season of our
life I should record that song Dave had
this amazing involuntary change that
happened to him so have you you've had
that happen to you where a friend you
ever talk to in three years calls you up
and says I know we haven't connected but
there's a job I think it's perfect for
you so you have to add this other line
to the equation so if you've got a
vertical line that goes from voluntary
involuntary yet another line that goes
from negative to positive and when you
do that you see there's these four
different do-over moments that every
career is going to go through the first
is what's called a ceiling it's when you
are voluntarily going towards something
negative you're getting stuck
the second is an involuntary negative
moment that's called a bump you lose
your job another company buys your
company and lays off your sales team
maybe it's smaller than that maybe at an
amazing manager who loved you and fought
to hire you and then left that company a
month after you got there or you were
part of a great team where you knew how
to work with this
team and they shuffled things and now
you're on a new team and you're
vulnerable and you've gone through a
bump moment but what about on the other
side of the equation the positive
moments a voluntary positive decision
when you willingly decide to change your
life is called the jump it's a jump
moment New York City is a jump city
where people come here and they jump
towards something positive starting a
blog is a jump moment reading a book is
a jump moment going to a conference
taking a class it's you saying I'm going
to do something positive to change my
life and then the last one is a positive
moment that's involuntary where
something good out of your control
happens that friend calls you up out of
nowhere and offers you a job it comes in
a million different shapes I talked to a
CEO of a bank in Benton Harbor Michigan
I said how did you become CEO he said
well as a teller for a few years and
then my manager got arrested for
counterfeiting checks
so her job opened up do you think in his
five-year plan he said first three years
I'm gonna kill it being a manager and
really work hard and then hopefully
somebody above me will go to jail and
their job will open up of course not
he got this unexpected moment and so
that's what a career is about is
learning how to navigate these four
different seasons and it'd be great if
you could just eliminate the negative
side if you can just say I'm going to
make jump moments where I do positive
things eat so much kale and I'm gonna
have opportunity moments where surprise
has happened to me but if you're
watching this video you know that's not
how life works that's not how career
works you've gone through most of these
moments by 9:00 a.m. before you finish
your first coffee you'll say okay I'm in
a jump moment in this part of my career
but I'm gonna bump moment over here and
my relationship is stuck over here and
so what you have to do is navigate these
four different career do-overs
you